good morning john today joe biden is
probably going to sign the largest
single piece of climate change
legislation any country on our planet
has ever enacted but everything i have
read and i have read a lot is
frustratingly thin on detail and as i
tried to do the research myself on that
i i discovered why i've been going over
non-partisan analyses congressional
budget office reports talking to the
people who wrote those reports talking
to the administrator of the epa even in
some cases reading the actual text of
the 700-page bill and what i have found
has been a surprise but also a bit of
the delight so let's start at the
beginning
[Music]
around 4 billion years ago something
started to be alive on earth and ever
since then that life has had a profound
effect on the planet photosynthesizers
used sunlight to break up carbon dioxide
to build their bodies out of the carbon
and release the oxygen that oxygen made
all kinds of interesting weird things
happen including at one point killing
almost everything so no life creating
atmospheric change that has a profound
negative impact on life not actually new
over time life kept shoving energy into
carbon containing molecules and then
after the life died those molecules
would break down and the energy would be
re-released but sometimes the molecules
of the dead thing would stay trapped and
they wouldn't break down and they would
get stuck in the earth where they'd heat
up and get squished and become coal or
oil or natural gas all that energy
emitted by the sun grabbed by life and
then stored by the earth waiting there
to power your car or your refrigerator
or your microsoft zoom that energy is
what has powered so much of our modern
lives but as we have released that
energy to do things with we have also
released the original molecules that it
was stored inside of those complicated
carbon molecules get broken down and
carbon dioxide gets released it is a
molecule that is opaque to a lot of
infrared radiation a gas that makes our
atmosphere less clear to heat and so
heat that would otherwise escape no
longer is there is more energy in the
atmosphere and it's changing weather
patterns increasing droughts and fires
and storms and heat waves but
unfortunately we also really need all of
that energy to prevent people from dying
in heat waves to make the food that
people eat to move it around and to
power the plane that takes me to visit
my brother we can't just turn the power
plants off people would start dying very
quickly and they wouldn't stop for a
really really long time it's messy and
it's complex and like those first
cyanobacteria people started to wonder
if we weren't gonna just ruin it for
ourselves but we are smarter than them
and we are more capable of passing
broad-based industrial policy with a
focus on clean energy than they are
barely
just barely and that brings us up to now
[Music]
in 2005 a couple of years before this
youtube channel began the us hit peak
carbon emissions of 7 billion tons per
year at the time that problem looked
pretty insurmountable this is jesse
jenkins one of the world's leading
experts on modeling decarbonization
efforts talking about those dark years
um you know at the time if you could get
a wind farm that cost less than a
hundred dollars a megawatt hour which is
like triple the you know normal
electricity rate that was a great deal
and solar was 10 times the cost of
normal you know power from a gas plant
or something but over the last decade
you know due to supportive policies in
the us but also abroad in you know china
and germany and japan and elsewhere
we've taken these what we used to call
expensive alternative energy
technologies that at the time people
were worried we couldn't get you know 5
or 10 or 15 percent of our electricity
from without blowing up the grid and now
there are cheap trillion dollar
mainstream you know technologies that
are scaling rapidly and are powering you
know in the case of some parts of the
country the majority of our electricity
on certain days i am in what seems to be
a weird situation of being more
optimistic now than i was 20 years ago
because in that time i have seen a lot
of change since this youtube channel
began we have dropped from 7 billion
tons to 5 billion tons emitted per year
in the u.s in the next 15 years
according to jesse's models which
admittedly are trying to predict the
future we will probably get down to 3.5
billion tons 50 lower than our peak this
week i was able to talk to michael regan
the head of the epa and he also talked
about this optimism even when i talked
to past ep administrators the role
technology plays in the solutions that
we're seeking the quickness of
innovation and the evolution of business
models matching with technology and
science and data we can move much faster
than we've ever moved before we are
aiming for net zero carbon emissions in
america by 2050 and this is the first
time in my life that i have felt like
that might be possible we have never
undergone a shift in energy use that is
anything like this maybe the original
electrification of the country but we're
gonna have to make this shift a lot
faster than we made that shift however
complex you think this is it's more
complex than that in this case even for
experts like we only ever get to see our
own little corner of what's going on
this is a big problem that no one person
understands all of but in this video
you're going to go from understanding
more than like 80 or 90 of people to
understanding this more than 99 of
people it's only going to take you like
15 minutes so let's do this what's this
okay i like it picasso this bill
basically has three big goals and i
don't see them being talked about so
here's the framework with which to
understand this one we are trying to
decrease the amount of carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gases we emit in
the atmosphere two we are trying to make
the impacts of climate change and
pollution and also this energy shift
less impactful on people or ideally a
good thing for people so that they like
it particularly we would like to
decrease the impacts on the most
disadvantaged people and third and this
is important to understand anything
that's going on here
this is a bill that is trying to make
the united states of america into an
industrial center of the clean
technology revolution now there are some
other smaller things in the build that
don't fit into any of these categories
we'll talk about them in the future but
that's the three big things oh look each
one of these blocks is a billion dollars
and there are 369 of them and we're
going to start filling them up first we
want to drive down the cost of
installing renewable energy projects
that's wind solar and grid scale
batteries that's going to lower people's
electricity bills and it's also going to
make it so that when you plug in your
electric car in the year 2027 we'll get
to that the power turning your wheels is
going to produce less carbon dioxide and
wow we have filled up a lot of our
billions all this money is here to
incentivize power producers to use more
wind solar and grid scale batteries
that's going to reduce the amount of co2
being released in the atmosphere but
also it does the second thing does that
by decreasing electricity bills having
minimum wage requirements and
apprenticeship requirements and it does
the third thing by requiring that a lot
of the stuff that is going into these
projects solar panels batteries wind
turbines are made in america and the
components are either from america or
from our free trade allies if you've
ever played tony hawk pro skater you
know how like when you do like more than
one trick in a row you can get a
multiplier it's like that if you do any
of these individual things you get some
stuff but there's multipliers every time
you do more but hank i hear you saying
we don't make a lot of solar panels or
wind turbines or batteries in america
right now how are we going to be able to
source those from america don't worry
about that boom it's the second biggest
thing in the build the manufacturing tax
credits not only do the people buying
the thing get the tax credit but so the
people making the things we're building
out a whole industry here 37 billion
dollars is expected to go toward helping
companies make solar panels and
batteries and battery components and
wind turbines and etcetera etcetera and
they've got to be made in the u.s and
they gotta hit those wage and
apprenticeship requirements but hank you
continue to be concerned solar power and
wind power they're intermittent you
can't expect them to be on all the time
and those batteries they're gonna handle
some of that shifting but not all of it
that is right we need firm power power
that you can turn on whenever you need
it and the biggest piece of cash in this
bill that goes toward that goes toward
existing nuclear power plants helping
them stay open and keep operating
existing carbon free electricity with
tax breaks but only if you meet wage and
apprenticeship requirements probably
just expect that everything you hear
about is going to have wage and
apprenticeship requirements because this
bill has to be good for people and also
there need to be people to work on these
things so you need to be training people
and you need to be paying them well also
focused on firm power are smaller
investments in potential future
technologies like advanced nuclear power
advanced geothermal and advanced
biofuels we don't know which of those
things is going to be the best or most
impactful but all of them could end up
being important players in carbon-free
firm power all right so now this
hypothetical person who's basically
constructing the bill with me is
concerned that we're giving a lot of
money to power plants not a lot of money
to people how about 22 billion dollars
for you and another 14 billion after
that and then 12 billion after that the
22 billion dollars goes to help people
upgrade their appliances in their homes
like water heaters furnaces stoves and
even just their electrical boxes to
handle all of that new electricity
because guess what you might not have
noticed your house currently has an
exhaust pipe it is extremely likely that
you have power coming into your house in
two ways the electricity that powers the
lights and the microwave and your
microsoft zune and then there's the gas
power that powers your furnace and your
water heater and maybe your stovetop
possibly even your clothes dryer all of
that means that your house chugs out co2
and there isn't an easy way to clean
that up without replacing those methane
burning appliances with appliances that
run on electricity if you can't do that
not only are you just releasing a lot of
carbon dioxide also you're reliant on a
single source of fuel for your heat and
your hot water and that fuel price can
fluctuate a lot while electricity costs
don't fluctuate as much and those
fluctuations hit low income people extra
hard because fuel costs and energy costs
are a higher portion of what they spend
their money on so this 22 billion goes
toward helping people buy and in some
cases outright covering the entire cost
of appliances that electrify these
previously gas-powered things heat pumps
to heat and cool homes using electricity
heat pump water heaters electric or
induction stovetops just buying one of
these appliances saves people money in
the long term already folks usually
can't afford the upfront costs of that
especially doing all of these things at
the same time well no longer the next 14
billion are to help people and property
owners make their buildings more
efficient and these last 12 billion are
for you guessed it electric vehicle tax
credits that you probably can't use i
know what you're thinking all that
sounded so great until that last part
why can i not use my electric vehicle
tax credit because of the third thing
these cars also have manufacturing
requirements and when this bill goes
into effect the number of cars that will
qualify for that
is quite small and they will all be sold
very quickly now there were already tax
credits on electric vehicles but those
credits only apply for the first 200 000
vehicles from each manufacturer and many
manufacturers gm tesla etc have already
burned through all those this extends
those indefinitely for the next 10 years
but only if they meet the requirements
because again the bill is about all
three things other countries have had
this kind of industrial policy for
decades and that has allowed them to
build up their industries producing
these things and the people who crafted
this bill for better or worse want the
u.s to have that kind of industrial
policy it now looks like we are more
than halfway through the things that
this build does but we are not down here
things start to get much more dense uh
and then you realize that there are
actually hundreds of ways that this bill
spends money and each one of them does a
different thing for different people in
different places like hank what about
the carbon impact of forest fires yeah
that is in there how about decarbonizing
airplane fuels yeah early stages in
trying to get that done that's in there
converting garbage trucks and city buses
to electric it definitely does that tax
incentives for existing power plants to
capture their emissions yeah three
billion dollars for that electrifying
most of the postal service fleet another
three billion for that reconnecting
communities that were divided by the
interstate highway system yes 3 billion
for that too helping farmers figure out
systems for sequestering carbon in their
fields sure cleaning up and electrifying
port infrastructure definitely that
early market creation for low carbon
building materials also in there new
transmission lines because all of this
electrification is going to require more
robust grid yeah that too charging
stations for evs got that as well grants
for tribes to invest in clean energy got
that too buying debt from rural power
co-ops if they promise to shut down
their carbon emitting power plants and
giving them money to build new
infrastructure that's in there too
there's a lot of things that are trying
to do really specific individual things
but there's also big hunks in here that
aren't prescriptive it's money for
communities to do things that they want
to do to decrease their impact here's
epa administer michael regan again
talking about that a lot of these grant
dollars that are in the act we're able
to give those to community groups who
are partnering with universities and
incubation centers the matching dollars
and the low interest loans are available
to people who have never been at the
table if we get these universities and
these these these young adults these
incubation centers
really tackling these issues with
community groups on the ground
these solutions can look a thousand and
one different ways and we have to feed
all of these solutions to see which ones
work for each individual community we
don't have to accept the notion that
there's a one size fit all you can look
a thousand and one different ways but
hank this hypothetical person who was
walking me through this entire bill is
now asking me why are we doing all of
these individual things instead of just
doing the one thing
if you did one thing it would do
everything and that's just to make
fossil fuels more expensive gretchen
stop trying to make fetch happen it's
not going to happen a few years ago an
ex-lobbyist from exxonmobil was caught
on video saying this nobody is going to
to propose a tax on all americans and
the cynical side of me says yeah we kind
of know that but it gives us a talking
point that we can say well what is exxon
mobil for well we're for a carbon tax
here's the thing we passed this bill
staring down the highest inflation rate
in decades and five dollar per gallon
gas there are two ways to incentivize
the move toward clean energy we can make
clean energy cheaper and we can make
fossil fuels more expensive and with
people already having a hard time
getting their butts to work nobody in
congress was going to keep their jobs if
they intentionally made fuel costs go up
this bill is very nearly all carrots for
clean energy and just a few sticks for
fossil fuels but i will talk about those
sticks now because one of them i love
very much methane is the most simple
carbon containing molecule and it is
even better at trapping heat than carbon
dioxide over the short term it's 80
times better at trapping heat and as
we've moved away from coal and toward
natural gas which is basically just
methane that has been good because
methane is a more efficient fuel you get
more heat per carbon dioxide molecule
that you release except that at every
step of the way methane can leak into
the atmosphere at the wellhead at the
pipeline at the compressor at the
infrastructure that delivers it to your
house and the facilities that use it the
methane emissions reduction program
provides incentives to fix leaks and
acquire more advanced systems for
keeping methane from being released and
it also pays for teams to check and see
if there are methane leaks and charge
increasingly hefty fines to the
companies that are releasing this
entirely usable potent greenhouse gas
into the atmosphere those fines go up
and up and up until they generate a
fairly significant amount of revenue as
it forces these companies to clean up
their app the other sticks against
fossil fuels are fairly minor they
reinstate the superfund tax which is
basically a big pool of money that
polluters pay into and that money is
then used to rehabilitate the damage
that they do to the environment it is a
super fund when i was a kid i thought it
was the super fund program it's not that
there's also an increase in the
percentage of money that the government
gets back from oil companies when they
take oil and gas off of federal land and
finally there's an increase in the cost
of holding a lease without developing it
so just having it sit there and not
using it there's an increase in that
cost both of those are basically ways to
disincentivize companies from using
federal lands to produce oil and gas so
there are a couple of things to keep
fossil fuels a little more under control
but mostly we want their cost to remain
steady or even go down as demand for
them decreases because the alternatives
are just
better but also weirdly there's a couple
of carrots for fossil fuels
[Music]
since we are obsessed with anything and
everything that makes us feel bad if
you've heard anything about this bill
you have heard that joe manchin moderate
democrat forced the inclusion of a few
very weird provisions first and most
frustratingly he took a few oil and gas
leases in alaska and the gulf of mexico
that trump had authorized and then biden
had paused and people have been fighting
against for years and was like you want
my name on this you make those leases
happen it's super weird it's super
frustrating it's outside of the normal
process no one likes this
except for of course the oil and gas
companies in joe manchin and the other
thing was basically a way to prevent any
president or lawmakers in the next 10
years from banning fossil fuel leases on
federal land and it does this by tying
the ability to put clean energy projects
on federal land to a requirement to
offer leases for oil and gas drilling on
other separate federal land now an
offered lease is not a sold lease and a
sold lease is not an oil well but it is
still disappointing kind of gets stuck
in your throat even if modelers show
that the overall carbon effectiveness of
the bill only goes down by about two
percent because of these provisions but
imagine i guess got what he wanted out
of it which is everyone talking more
about how he loves fossil fuels and
they're his pretty little baby than the
entire rest of the bill and also he got
to be like one of the title names on the
bill despite being one of its
biggest opponents so
ah so now the right question to ask is
is all of this going to work and luckily
i have prepared for you more squares
each one of these is roughly 5 million
fewer tons of co2 and by 2030 there are
200 of them so that's roughly a billion
fewer tons of carbon dioxide per year
here's where we'll be decreased co2 and
transportation saves us 280 million tons
per year cleaner power generation saves
us 360 million tons cleaner industry
saves us 130 million cleaner buildings
save us around 70 million tons same for
the equivalent carbon dioxide effects of
mostly methane but also other greenhouse
gases produced by cars like nitric
oxides and finally carbon sequestration
in agricultural and forest lands gets us
a final 80 million tons and of course we
do not pause there the effects of these
changes are projected to get us down
another 500 million tons by 2035. i'm
aware that there are going to be people
who are going to be mad at me for being
pretty
unapologetically excited about this bill
like i'm mad that we lost the civilian
climate corps which would have been
thousands of young people working on the
ground on these problems i am frustrated
that we lost a lot of due process on
these oil leases and they weren't even
something that i was actively working on
so i can't imagine what it must be like
for the people who've been fighting
those battles look i don't know if it's
that i'm old now or that i'm privileged
in like a thousand ways or that i've
been through a number of climate fights
that went
very badly maybe i'm just thinking
practically about the fact that this
might be our last chance to get
something substantial done for years
like many years maybe especially because
there was every likelihood that this
could have just not happened like many
other parts of the original buildback
better didn't happen in fact four measly
weeks ago it seemed like it wouldn't
happen i got to talk to jesse jenkins
about that i was on vacation with my
family or leaving for vacation and i got
the call from senator schumer's staff
that the bill was dead same faces of
grief right shock
loss
anger and some people stopped at anger
and they just got mad at joe manchin on
the internet and and yelled at you know
he got cynical like you were talking
about and some of us um including some
members of you know a few handful of
members of the senate
again said no
this is not how it's going to end i
refuse to accept that so this is also
bargaining right that's one of the faces
of grief and we went back to work and we
bargained and it against all odds it
worked i had pretty well given up hope
that it was going to succeed at that
point given this is the second time the
rug was pulled out from under us you
know i wanted to be able to tell my kids
that we we fought to the very end and it
worked um and i am so grateful uh i'm
gonna cheer up a little for all the
people really that that did that because
it was very very close to failure i
don't harbor any illusions that i live
in a perfect world or a perfect country
or that perfect legislation exists there
are 330 million of us the fact that we
get anything done at all is a little
impressive and over the last 10 years we
have made tremendous strides in cutting
carbon emissions and that has been in
large part because of government
investment in the us and elsewhere
between 2009 and 2017 america spent
around 20 billion dollars per year
fighting climate change over the next 10
years we will spend 80 billion dollars
per year there are a lot of super
powerful people who have been working
really hard this whole time to slow this
down as much as they can at first they
say it doesn't exist then they say it's
not caused by people then they say it's
caused by people but it's not that big
of a deal then they say it's that big of
a deal but the costs to take it on are
too great we have hit them with reality
at every step in that process and we're
gonna hit them with reality at this step
of the process too they will tell us
that the costs are too great and after
we prove to them that it's not they will
tell us that it's too late nothing gets
done if you don't believe it can't be
done and i for the first time
in decades of this
have started to believe that it can be
done and it's happening i think for two
reasons one because of the very hard
work of a lot of people from policy to
science to communication and outreach
and two because it is getting hard to
ignore the very real effects of all of
this extra energy in our atmosphere and
in our oceans we might be in a very
narrow window here a moment when the
effects are too present for anyone to
ignore anymore
but not so present that they will hold
us back from implementing solutions i
don't know how long that window's gonna
be open and i was not sure that it was
open until
somebody did something and said
something and they kept working and they
kept pushing and they kept
making the case that this needed to be
done until it got done but now it feels
like the window's open it does not feel
like we are done one big step does not
get you over the mountain pass there is
much more to do but as i've been saying
i am more optimistic now that this is a
challenge that we can actually take on
than i have been maybe in my entire
career john i'll see you on tuesday
heads up my full interviews with jesse
jenkins and administrator regan are up
over on hank's channel i learned a ton
from both of them they're fascinating
conversations there's links in the
description and also just a general
thank you to everyone and there are
thousands of you who worked in some way
on this bill either advocating or
writing or doing policy analysis like
it's a big thing both on my behalf but
also on behalf of like my son who's
going to be around for more of this
future and i want his future to be one
that i can believe and one where the
fair rides that he loves so much are
powered by clean energy and you're
helping with that so thanks